he's Dave siren the sports editor of the
nation host of The Edge's sports podcast
and he joins us here in the man cave
I just found out that you're teaching a
class in college now in sports history
I am Montgomery College shout out right
out there in Takoma Park Maryland it's
an absolute thrill love my students a
lot of them listen to the show actually
so shout out to all of them as well
it's absolutely thrilling because I see
them learning some of the basics of
sports history things that I think we
take for granted like who is Jackie
Robinson what was the impact of Muhammad
Ali how did Billie Jean King changed the
world and their eyes they just become as
big as saucers they never saw that you
cannot separate sports from the
political landscape but how much do they
not know it's pretty intense and that so
there a lot of the teaching is about the
basics like what was the 1930s what was
the Great Depression why did it matter
that Jackie Robinson was a World War two
veteran what did that mean to black
America in terms of World War two and so
some of that is you have to go through
the basics but they're like sponges so
it's it's a lot of fun but if you were
going to have one sports moment that you
wanted to teach what would be good wow
that's a fantastic question if I had one
moment I would want to teach I think it
would be the Thrilla in Manilla I would
want to talk about Muhammad Ali and Joe
Frazier at great length because a lot of
my students are in the UFC and I think
there's a very interesting similarity
between khabib and Conor McGregor and
that thrill in Manila fight between
Frazier and Ali like the fact that
before that fight Ali for Ali it was a
game for Ali it was bringing people out
he was calling Joe Frazier the gorilla
he was making fun of the blackness of
his skin and for him it was just like if
I make Frazier mad and if i polarize
people it's gonna bring more eyeballs to
the fight but for Joe Frazier it was not
a joke for Joe Frazier he was willing to
die in Manila because he was so deeply
offended by Ali and I could make that
about Connor and khabib and be like for
Conor it's a joke it's eyeballs he's
gonna make fun of Kobe's religion he's
gonna make fun of his family he's gonna
make fun of his country and for khabib
then it becomes life and death how would
Ali be treated now in his in his prime I
mean it's interesting because Ali would
have social media
so in some respects Olli was social
media before social media and that he
was able to get out his message despite
the fact that the overwhelming majority
of the media in the mid 1960s was
against the kind of things he was saying
and what he was standing for but I think
that if Ali was around today he'd be
able to leverage social media to a
degree that no athlete could even
compare like it wouldn't even be close
LeBron James would be taking lessons
from Muhammad Ali in terms of how to
leverage social media and get his
message out and I think that would be
different and that would create him an
army of followers in a way that the
media would have to respond to and not
be so overwhelmingly negative towards
him which they were in the 1960 you have
to wait till the 1970s before a new
generation of writers are like hey this
guy is not only good copy he has
something to say and maybe he was right
about Vietnam as the rest of the country
was moving in that direction to say it
was a mistake and maybe we should pay
him respect for the courage that he
displayed during those difficult times
but why is it some of the most seminal
moments in our history have to do with
african-americans with Jesse Owens in
1936 you got Jackie Robinson what
Muhammad Ali is doing
I don't know how history is going to
look at Colin Kaepernick yeah I don't
like the comparisons to Ali I think it's
different with Ali but we're trying to
lump him in there and and I know he's
been treated as a hero in some sections
but how do you think history looks back
because history has been very kind to
Ali
yes but it took a long time how will how
will we look at Colin Kaepernick in 20
years I'll say similarly history has
been very kind to John Carlos and Tommie
Smith and we're about to hit the 50th
anniversary of Mexico City in 1968 and
explain that to those Sports Illustrated
had a wonderful are terrific
and it looked back on the 50 years and
you know who these two athletes were
1968 Olympics in Mexico City yeah it was
John Carlos and Tommie Smith and Peter
Norman the silver medalist in Austria
yup who stood in solidarity with them
they were athletes who in the lead-up to
the olympics we're talking about a
boycott as a protest against racism and
a protest for human rights they were
talking about a boycott of the 1968
Olympics just not going and the boycott
fell through but they decided that they
still needed to make some kind of
statement so after the 200-meter race
John Carlos and Tommie Smith raised
their fists on the medal stand and Peter
Norman wore a button that said Olympic
project for Human Rights in solidarity
with them and black gloves black gloves
raised to the heavens they weren't
wearing shoes to protest poverty they
were wearing beads and necklaces as a
symbol of the history of of lynchings
and violence in the United States so it
was a very intense moment and it was
made all the more intense a lot of
people don't realize this that was the
first Olympics ever shown in color and
so the whole world was seeing it in a
much more vivid way than they saw say
1964 in Tokyo or anything like that so
it electrified audiences at polarized
audiences and it infuriated audiences to
a profound degree and both those men
suffered in a way that you know you
could certainly argue that Colin
Kaepernick because you asked about that
hasn't had to suffer in the same kind of
way like they spent decades um in
periods of poverty decades in the
wilderness decades being ignored and
John Carlos was working as a custodian
for a number of years he had terrible
family tragedies during that time Tommy
says Tommy sees his mother died I mean
she was sent all sorts of hate mail and
even dead animals in the mail and it was
it was a horrific thing and it took
about 40 years it really took til the
early mid 2000s before they got
rediscovered and appreciated and statues
of them were built at San Jose State
University and they were given the ESPN
Arthur Ashe award for courage and and so
that they've been there's been this
really she ation and you're seeing it
more now because of people like Colin
Kaepernick and this idea that there is
this tradition of athlete activism and
that that's something that as someone I
consider john-carlos to be like family
to me I did it I did his book with him
and you know we speak every week he's
he's a dear person to me and we started
knowing each other back in 2003 when he
was working as a guidance counselor in
the public school system of California
and he was this kind of unknown figure
and kind of lost in history and to see
him be appreciated over the last 15
years and to see him open up has been
one of the great blessings of my life
I'll never forget I want to do is
interview him because he was from New
York I was working for a very small
newspaper in Prince George's County
Maryland and I just thought how cool
would it be to interview the bronze
medalist that guy and I knew you was
from New York and I'm from New York and
I thought this will be a cool story
so I googled him online and up came a
website that looked like an angel fire
website from like 1993 those very old
school you know geo cities websites and
there was like this a picture of him and
a phone number at the bottom and I just
called the phone number and I got a
public school in Palm Springs California
and this gruff voice saying hello and I
said hi I'm trying to track down John
Carlos this is Carlos who the hell is
this I was like uh I don't want to
interview you because you don't want to
hear what I have to say and then a
couple more let's just say profanities
followed about how little I would
actually want to hear his truth and but
then I interviewed him and published
every word he said and it just started a
relationship it doesn't help Colin
Kaepernick's College if he doesn't play
again uh in in so many respects I think
it does and it's so interesting you say
that cuz I was thinking back to a time I
was on this show in the fall of 2017 and
you asked me if I thought he would get
signed for the coming season and I said
no and you were surprised and then I
hedged a little bit and there was this
idea well of course he's gonna get
signed because someone is gonna need him
but it's like as the months have gone on
and as he hasn't been signed the memory
of a quarterback who is probably on the
who who is just the memory of a
quarterback who you would not say was in
the Tom Brady class you know has faded
and this iconic status has developed I
mean he's he's at Harvard today
accepting a w eb des bois award i mean
so the legend has grown and in so many
respects it's helped him for whatever he
wants to do in the years ahead
why is he not doing interviews that's a
great question I mean I have theories
about that I mean because I've certainly
tried to interview him and I've
contacted him and asked but he's writing
a book I believe I and that's what I was
told that he's saving everything for the
book saving everything for the book and
he also has a television series about
his high
school years that he signed with Ava
Duvernay the the director of sale of
Selma and it's so I think that there's
this idea that the Miss like from him
and the people around him that that the
mystique and symbolism of him
matters more than anything he has to say
that's what they've kind of figured out
and it's hard to disagree with them
because it's almost like the less he
says yeah the more curious people are
about him I mean he did this thing for
GQ magazine where he was named there I
think like Sports comports person of the
year in some respects and he didn't do
an interview with him he was just a
pictorial and other people wrote essays
about his meaning to them and it's it's
savvy in a way that I think it's almost
like the anti ollie it's it's it's
Sphinx Ian almost where the less he says
the more you're curious about what he
wants to say he's the Mona Lisa smile of
activists athletes we're talking to
Dave's ayran he is the sports editor of
the nation and host of the edge of
sports podcast ten years from now if
you're still teaching this class yeah
what would you teach your students about
LeBron James I would say that you can't
understand the way the fundamental
landscape of sports and politics has
shifted without understanding LeBron
James for two reasons the first is that
LeBron James was the first great athlete
to realize that the goal is not to be as
pleasant to as many people as possible
and it's non-threatening to as many
people as possible but in this social
media landscape you can actually create
more buzz by getting about 3/4 of the
people to love you and one fourths of
the people to not like you but to talk
about you all the time that that you
know it's one of those as long as they
spell your name right he was that really
the first athlete since Ollie to get
that right the second thing I would
teach them is that LeBron James created
a shield for an entire generation of
athletes to speak out because if LeBron
James the most famous athlete in the
United States could do it then they
could they could do it too and the last
thing I would teach them is if you want
to understand the shift from what I
would consider the Jordan era to the
LeBron era
it starts with him getting the entire
Miami Heat team to wear hoodies back in
2012 and take that photograph or years
before Kaepernick and to take a
photograph in solidarity with Trayvon
Martin in Florida and that if you don't
understand that image which was a viral
image when we were only first talking
about Twitter and viral images then you
can't understand anything that followed
so I think LeBron James is actually that
important that you can't understand an
era of what's taking place off the court
without understanding LeBron James and
now that he's in Los Angeles and he's
even moving on to becoming like mogul /
basketball player and from what I hear
every time he walks into a studio or a
production room I'm in Hollywood he
leaves with money he leaves with another
deal another documentary idea another
show idea I mean the guy is cleaning up
in Hollywood like nobody since DW
Griffith and I think this in and of
itself is going to burnish his legend
and so we don't even know what his
legacy is gonna be at this point do you
think Jordan would have been capable of
this like is he wired to do what if I
gave him a mulligan and said you know
what you could be playing in today's
generation you know I honestly don't
think so I mean I think he would be
revered for his play but the idea of
being this outspoken person on social
media this idea of feeling like he needs
to say something when there's a social
cause that's risen to the occasion I
don't think he's wired though and he's
done interviews where he's spoken about
why he's not wired that way and speaks
of himself in terms of being a
post-civil rights athlete and growing up
in this stable home and Wilmington North
Carolina and just not feeling that in
the same kind of way that he may say
that other people expected him to feel
that and so I mean there are athletes
today certainly there's legions of them
who who don't speak out and still
believe in the actually this this goes
back to people like Joe Lewis and Althea
Gibson like people who said let our play
is going to do the talking and that in
and of itself is our contribution to the
broader society I truly think that
that's the camp Jordan would be in it's
just hard to imagine I mean maybe it
would be different everyone's a product
of their times but it
it's just hard to figure I think he'd be
the Aaron judge of of basketball but
also when you look at Michael Jordan
there was so much privacy - yes and
people didn't write about things that
they would be writing about now with
today's athletes and I think that you
know I just can't see Jordan wanting to
share more of himself whereas LeBron
sort of grew up in this today's athlete
grows up and in this and just says only
it's commonplace that I share pictures
and I share you know everything about my
life on and off the field on and off the
court yeah that they're growing up now
with this idea that they're on camera 24
hours a day and that they need to
document what they're doing 24 hours a
day and this is part of not just how you
function in society but also how you
build a brand those magic three words
that every athlete gets put in their
head as soon as they enter the league
and I think for Jordan it's like he was
willing to let the companies build the
brand for him I can't imagine him saying
I'm going to build my own brand through
social media and basically give it away
for free and as opposed to getting paid
by haines by ballpark franks and by nike
to be able to build this brand for me if
i gave you a chance to interview any
athlete in history just one from a
particular time i mean this is gonna
sound very basic but I would go with two
then so I'm not so basic because the
basic answer would be Muhammad Ali in
1968 when he's banned from boxing when
he's doing a series of lectures on the
college circuit and I would love just to
speak to him about how he was feeling
being that alone but also immersed in
the world and then the other person I'd
like to talk to is Paul Robeson in the
1920s when he was absolute football star
it was our first black star in the NFL
or the first black player in the NFL
ya know it's it's interesting cuz the
NFL it had players like Paul Robeson and
Charles pholis and and fritz Pollard you
know the great fritz Pollard in the
1920s and it was an integrated league
and it doesn't segregate until like 1933
at the behest of George Preston Marshall
the owner of the Washington football
team and the last team to integrate in
the NFL and then it integrates again
1946-1947
with players like woody strode and Kenny
Washington and the great Marion motley
and Bill Willis with Paul Brown and
Cleveland and so there's this by the way
I'm teaching my students this stuff and
they're their eyes just like they'd love
that I'm sorry I just I love this stuff
so I think they love this stuff too but
Paul Robeson was such a star and he
helped integrate the team at Rutgers and
he was a terrific player and he was
abused by his own teammates until he
proved himself physically who's that the
less time Rutgers was good oh wow Ray
Rice I mean we've doesn't New Jersey get
enough black ice where you got
Springsteen and Bon Jovi what more do
you want
yeah that's enough yes so I would talk
to Paul Robeson what about you Dan who
would you interview any athlete in
history
I think Babe Ruth allowed to understand
the magnitude of because it was word of
mouth that it was a he was it was this
larger-than-life figure did he know it
how big a celebrity was he what was he
like off the field
did his teammates like him just you know
his whole background where you know
where he came from was he an you know he
was an orphan like just there was a lot
that went into who he was what he was
all about but to be that great in that
time when you're reading newspapers and
the power of reading about this
mythological figure like Babe Ruth I
thought Babe Ruth was 64 you know 230
yeah I believe rich Aurilia of the
Giants was the same size as Babe Ruth so
511 215 was what was Wow but but you
know you think of these guys like Jack
Nicklaus first time I met Jack oh it oh
my god he it's like 510 yeah because you
know you grow up listening or reading
and then you see and then I thought oh
my god he's got to be huge and then you
realize he wasn't so babe you know sort
of the same way I'd love to know just
that impact and how big of a celebrity
he really was the great book is just
came out by Jane levy Oh gotta be
Highland
yeah yeah got to be I started it it's
it's
terrific she wrote the great Mickey
Mantle biography as well she wrote Sandy
Koufax - yeah she that's right the great
Jane levy well done the Babe Ruth one is
fascinating cuz then you also look at
people like Grantland rice and how they
created that myth and that that
generation of sports writers and what it
was about Ruth that was so charismatic
to them well you were able to do it and
you know to gain access you had to be
nice like they were the writers were
your friends and they weren't you know
there wasn't I mean babe couldn't
survive now know that social media
imagine Babe Ruth with social media it
would make us people like Tristan
Thompson loved team I'll just say that
would babe data Kardashian without
question may be multiple probably - and
you know Chris - Kris Jenner yeah in
some respects maybe he was made for
these times we always learned you always
make a smarter Dave we appreciate your
time and thanks for coming through it is
such a thrill I get out when I'm here I
love it one of these days you got to
take inventory here of the man cave I
would love to do an article on the man
you should come in and just you know
just peruse soak soak it up you need to
ask questions I can explain if you could
take one thing out of the man cave mmm
that's a great question that have so
many possibilities I I like the picture
of you throwing out the first pitch in a
st. Louis Cardinals uniform I would take
that first of all cuz the motions
fantastic I mean it you look like a
young Rick Ankiel Rick thank you a
right-handed Rick thank you yes and I
got it over the plate of amazing yeah I
couldn't hit like him Lance Armstrong is
yellow jersey over there that's a great
possibility that would be on the list
for sure said he had a pile of those he
did I got a pile of them I was
hopefully deodorize yeah no I didn't
mind that Landon Donovan's Jersey that
that was not deodorized that wasn't
watch my favorite is the Peyton Manning
mmm Ryan Leaf Jersey
so if leaf had been drafted by the Colts
they made a Jersey for him we have that
one over there one of a kind and Ryan
Leaf signed it for us that's the one at
usually people go wait Ryan Lee play for
the
yeah no we didn't but that's where
that's how divided they were in that no
matter what they tell you they were
divided on taking Ryan Leaf and Peyton
Manning Ryan beyond belief was chris
burrman great to see you thank you again
siren sports editor the nation edge of
the host of edge of sports podcast for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]